le reportage de l'émission enquête qui
fait état d' allégations d'agression
sexuelle et d' abus de pouvoir de huit
policiers de la sûreté du québec de val
d'or contre des femmes autochtones de
val d'or créé une onde de choc
ces policiers ont été relevés de leurs
fonctions ils ne font face mentionnons
le à aucune accusation pour le moment et
l'enquêté a été confiée au service de
police de la ville de montréal se joint
à nous madame isabelle picard et les
membres de la nation huronne wendat
anthropologue directrice de la fondation
nouveau sentier bonjour madame madame
picard nous ce qui nous a interpellé
c'est votre lettre ouverte publiée
aujourd'hui dans le devoir dans la
presse où vous dites c'est assez ont été
très touchés par la teneur de vos propos
j'aimerais entendre que vous fassiez
pour les gens qui n'ont pas eu
l'occasion de vous lire
j'aimerais que vous nous témoignez un
petit peu de votre cri du coeur qu'est
ce que ça a évoqué chez vous en fait je
me suis réveillée jeudi matin avec mon
fils d'actualités facebook qui
mentionnait un peu des bribes de ligne
sont en 4k d'avoir lieu le réseau
autochtone est très fort l'ombre des
réseaux sociaux
et là j'ai eu envie de tout fermer ça
puis de me dire ok non c'est assez je
veux plus entendre parler de ça ça fait
trop d'histoires comme ce qu'on entend à
travers les années j'ai vécu dans
plusieurs communautés j'en ai visité
l'ensemble des communautés autochtones
du québec et on entend trop souvent une
question d'autorité qui vaut prendre
avantage des personnes les plus
vulnérables
alors c'est sûr que j'ai réagi avec
dégoût avec tristesse avec beaucoup
d'empathie beaucoup de compassion envers
ces femmes autochtones là et c'est un
peu ce que je décris dans ma tête et
votre mère qui vous dit ben non toi tu
n'es pas comme l'histoire un revers qui
vous disent à qui vous dit ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas votre parcours visiblement
vous êtes anthropologue vous avez un
tout autre parcours vous l'expliquez
comment cet écart entre vous et vos
soeurs qui la majorité ne sont pas
scolarisés non plus on l'entend beaucoup
trop souvent sommet vous c'est pas
pareil non mais vous c'est pas pareil
les amis autochtones
on entend toujours sûr mais on est
autant donner une partie de la réalité
aussi on en fait partie
les autochtones c615 collectivités au
canada c'est 50 premières nations qui
sont différents ce sont des réalités qui
sont différentes un peu partout je
dirais que j'étais tanné aussi
d'entendre sa piste est un peu à ce que
je voulais répondre aussi en disant que
non quand il ya un préjugé ou quand un
abus qui fait envers mais ça autochtone
et envers moi aussi qu'on a fait pire
envers toutes mes autres soeurs qui sont
plus éduqués ou plus qui consomme pas
aux autres c'est pas juste ce n'est pas
juste une stigmatisation confère à
l'égard de ces de ces femmes là c'est
tout le monde qu'on va tous vous parlez
aussi beaucoup de sa consommation de
drogue alcool et vous dites mais il ya
plus que ça oui il ya beaucoup plus que
cela le problème il est empirer le
problème il est historique le problème
il est systémique
encore aujourd'hui on les considérait
comme des mineurs aux yeux de la loire
on s'est toujours fait dire comment
penser on s'est fait les gens ont décidé
le gouvernement à décider pour nous ce
qui est tellement pour nous depuis
depuis des décennies depuis des
centaines d'années
le problème par des leurs je reviens on
prend davantage l'autorité qui prend
avantage les policiers ont pris avantage
des femmes plus vulnérables ça a été le
chaos selon le code des pensionnats
autochtones le gouvernement les
congrégations religieuses ont pris
avantage des enfants qui étaient
vulnérables
c'est toujours la même chose c'est tout
un système qui fait en sorte que découle
des problèmes comme l'alcool comme la
drogue comme la violence qu'on peut
vivre mais c'est ça c'est tout ce
système là qu'il faut étudier c'est pour
ce qu'ils font comme une commission
d'enquêté c'est une solution dans kate
est ce que vous avez bon avançant il y
aura une enquête policière sur ces faits
allégués puisque pour l'instant il n'y a
pas d'accusation criminelle quelqu'un
dit quel est votre confiance à l'endroit
de la police de montréal qui va mener l
enquête
c'est déjà mieux que la sq une qu'en cas
moi au départ c'était la sécu qui devait
enquêter sur la haye skull c'est la spvm
mais je crois que c'est absolument
essentiel que les autochtones qui sont
impliquées dans cette enquête là sinon
on va passer à côté encore puis la
neutralité
je peux certainement ce qu'on peut avoir
confiance en des policiers qui vont
enquêter sur des policiers je pose la
question vous avez un doute je pose la
question posée la question je voyais le
grand conseil des cris qui remet en
question ses activités qu'il doit être
que les activités annuelles ou enfin
qu'ils tiennent à val d'or qui disent on
aimerait peut-être mais que ce soit la
grc qui encaisse que vous en pensez en
fait je dirais qu'à ce niveau là ce qui
est important c'est qu'il ya une
certaine neutralité un certain
détachement et comme je l'aï dit tantôt
je pense que des autochtones qui
devraient pas être impliquées dans le
processus
à quel niveau qu'elle pourrait être
cette participation n'a produit que des
policiers autochtones
oui bien sûr il ya des policiers
autochtones donc ça pour être au niveau
policier mais on peut si on veut
vraiment mettre le doigt sur le bobo
faut aller un peu plus loin il faut
embaucher aussi des sociologues des
anthropologues et des histoires ignares
nos viandes plein chez les autochtones
je pense qu'il est temps aussi de deux
d'avoir une approche un petit peu plus
concertée par rapport à 7,74
oui tout à fait tout à fait parce qu'on
pourra pas juste expliquer sa part le
biais d'une enquête policière point je
pense que les causes vont être beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus d'importance
beaucoup plus face parce que les
enquêtes policières elle va sans doute
pas posé sur les gestes pour établir la
preuve est toujours c'est peut-être
parce que c'est là vraiment le forum
pour ce genre de parties d'inclusion là
je crois qu'on aura pas le choix je
crois que si on veut vraiment comprendre
pourquoi on est rendu là pourquoi qu'on
a eu des gestes comme cela on doit on
doit remonter à la source
et oui sans vie remonte à la sauce on
n'a pas souhaité en poche choix
d'élargir d'élargir maintenant les
libéraux fédéraux ont promis en campagne
électorale qu'il y aurait une enquête
nationale sur le sort de 1500 femmes
autochtones morts tôt disparu vous
quelles sont vos attentes concrètes
qu'est ce que vous attendez d'une telle
enquête j'attends ce qu' ils passent de
la parole aux actes
trop souvent on a vu des promesses de
gouvernement x y z et puyoô rien que cet
effet je pense aller comme ça on regarde
enquête a eu lieu en 96 18 3% des
recommandations finalement qui ont été
suivies donc étant qu'on parle vraiment
de la mission erasmus oui exact qu'on
passe de la parole aux actes donc le
gouvernement mettre en place une
commission d'enquêté c'est vraiment
important et quand
qu'on y met toute l'énergie qu'on y met
toute notre bon vouloir
je pense que des événements comme ceux
qui ont été soulevées à enquêtes vont
sensibilise les gens davantage je pense
qu'il ya un momentum % puis je m'attends
à ce que le gouvernement fait face on
travaille et qui se ferme pas les yeux
en terminant bon cette enquête là le
temps qu'elle se déploie qu'elle
s'organise à court terme
est ce qu'il ya des gestes concrets qui
pourrait changer des choses parce que ça
va être long la halle enquête
ouais on sait comment c'est laborieux
tous être sur pied définir les objectifs
bons à court terme
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui
pourraient être faites moi je devrais
déjà d'un poste fermé les yeux de
décrier les événements qui se passent de
d'essayer de les comprendre essayer
d'être plus ouverts moi je pense que
c'est déjà un pas dans la bonne
direction
entendu à leur écoute et isabelle picard
au plaisir de vous recevoir de nouveau
parmi nous on va suivre tout ce qui se
passe devant relier à 7 à cette affaire
et donc je mentionne que vous êtes sûrs
en huit dates anthropologue et
directrice de la fondation nouveau
sentier qui vient en aide aux jeunes
oui mais non seulement l'occasion de
reparler de cette fondation